hi miss coffeebean and i would like to
discuss something with you
natural language understanding
benchmarking or nlu benchmarking in
short
why should we care you can have the best
machine learning algorithm in the world
but if your data is crap your model
won't be much better and since our goal
is to achieve natural language
understanding is it though
yes of course it is how else should my
smart fridge ever truly understand me so
because we want to achieve nlu we also
need ways to measure how far we are
getting there but according to this
position paper nlu benchmarking is
broken so in this video we are going to
discuss how nlu benchmarking is
conducted nowadays why it is broken and
what this paper proposes to do about
this of course all of this is sprinkled
with a little bit of miss coffee beans
opinion here and there we will try to
make it clear where this is the case nlu
benchmarking why is this even a thing
don't laugh but the way researchers
measure progress towards machine
learning systems that can understand the
natural language is through tests and
benchmarks it's school all over again
but now the machine learning models are
writing the test i don't know why this
procedure is so hilarious to miss coffee
bean come on miss coffee bean how else
should we go on about it we need to
measure to quantify and write all of it
down i mean imagine a tree in a forest
growing so big that it achieved an lu
did it even achieve nlu if there was no
scientist to measure it and write a
paper about it of course not so here we
are at the starting point of this paper
at tests and benchmarks containing a lot
of examples that the model should get
right to achieve nlu collections of data
examples or in short benchmark data
datasets can be something like superglue
containing data from various tasks that
challenge these models to give you one
example let's take the word in context
subpart of superglue probing for word
sense disambiguation here the model
reads in two sentences and must decide
whether a word used in both sentences
has the same sense or not in this
example bad has a different meaning in
the two sentences of course there are
many other tasks like reading
comprehension which is also probed by
the squad 2 english reading
comprehension leaderboard if you have
heard of it
anyway the point here is that guess what
biased models that are not at all at nlu
level are able to solve these benchmarks
now we won't get into the philosophical
rabbit hole of asking who decides that
these systems are biased and are not at
the level of nlu although they solve the
examples probing for nlu even better
than humans because it's a sensitive
area where goal posts are either moved a
lot or people themselves have different
opinions on where the goal post even is
but let's formulate the general
consensus like this although the models
solve these nlu benchmarks in particular
they do not seem capable of nlu in
general they possess the biases
specifically required for these
benchmarks but not for other things in
other words these models don't solve the
task they only solve the data sets taken
from yet another angle they solve the
examples for the wrong reasons what are
the right reasons coffee bean quiet
that's complicated maybe something for
another video anyway to counter the
problems of usual benchmarks where
models are exploiting data advices and
spurious correlations left in there like
when an answer is correlated with a
specific word benchmarks like dyna bench
are going away from the classical id
benchmark and goes into adversarial mode
by asking human annotators to try to
fool neural models or at least a
reference neural model but as the
authors of this paper highlight
adversarially constructed benchmarks
will produce challenging examples i mean
they are built specifically such that
the models are set up to fail but they
also argue that this again doesn't help
to produce a better way of benchmarking
nlu because these examples can be
circumvented by producing models that
drop one set of the bad reasons it used
to solve the task without understanding
it and just choose another set of bad
reasons that are not targeted by the
adversarial benchmark so the point here
is that usual benchmarks are broken
because of biases that adversarial
benchmarks do not solve the problem
either so the authors propose four new
criteria that benchmarks should satisfy
let's see what these four criteria are
[Music]
we decide benchmarks should offer a
valid test of the full set of relevant
language phenomena oh god what does this
even mean it should be built around
consistently labeled safely being
explained should offer adequate
statistical power i don't get it and
they should disincentivize the use of
systems with potentially harmful bias oh
god let's take it slow and see how the
authors break up each of these points
into digestible pieces the first
criterion is the validity of the test
this means that if system a scores
higher than the system b
then a should be better at the task it
was tested at of course this criterion
will be violated by a system b
exploiting biases in the data set the
authors go on arguing how naturally
occurring examples think about data
sample script from the internet are not
guaranteeing validity since natural
distributions reflect the biases in the
wild but they also won't necessarily
tickle out the relevant abilities for
language comprehension from the model
because answers can be achieved also
through factual knowledge rather than
understanding just imagine a reading
comprehension task where the model must
extract who the president of the united
states is from a text well it does not
need to if it has memorized this fact
okay miss coffee bean but surely
examples generated by experts should do
the trick right
no
what do you mean no
well
expert authored examples have problems
too they are expensive that's sure but
experts are human too and will introduce
their own selection bias or phenomena
they are studying for example so expert
annotation does not guarantee broad
testing coverage for model abilities
either okay miss coffee bean what else
is there in the paper um lastly
crowdsourcing where random people on the
internet construct data there is no
surprise i guess that it is broken too
because annotators are conserving energy
which is just a physicist's way of
saying lazy therefore they are
generating repetitive easy cases i can
speak from my own experience here i
worked with the visual dialogue data set
where crowd workers had to create a
dialogue given an image in its caption
by going through the examples it is
clear how uninspired some annotators
were since too many examples just talk
about the picture in general and ask if
that is in color or not instead of
focusing more on what is happening in
the image which would have been the
desired annotation okay so what would
the perfect test set look like if it
were valid
well the authors do not really propose
the solution otherwise this wouldn't be
a position paper but a paper presenting
the data set implementing this solution
right but they service some promising
directions where crowdsourcing is
combined with expert annotations so
where experts are filling in the gaps
that laymen could not fill or by
offering bonuses to crowd workers when
they avoid overused words and
constructions well and if everything
about the first criterion isn't going so
well wait until you see the second
criterion of reliable annotation
how many times have you gone through
your data and saw wrong labels well this
is either due to careless mislabeling or
just because the annotation guidelines
were unclear or underspecified oh i know
that one or annotators themselves cannot
agree on one single label and if the
benchmark has such errors we can see the
effect of superhuman performance on
benchmarks while one human only tries to
solve the task with his own judgments
that might not reflect the judgment of
other annotators models can pick up the
patterns of the most frequent judgments
and herewith they surpass any single
human annotator the solution to this is
careful planning and testing of
annotation guidelines or not compressing
three annotations into one but keeping
the annotation distribution there to
analyze how this fits with the
prediction distribution of the model
cool the third criterion is about the
benchmarks statistical power the size of
the data should be large and
discriminative enough such that
differences between two models quality
can be significantly detected fulfilling
this is becoming harder and harder as
the models get better because models
start solving all easy examples
correctly and when easy examples make up
most of the data models start to differ
only in the long tail containing only
few samples and not delivering
statistical significance the solution
it's simple get more data but well the
reality is expensive everything costs
especially when talking about more
difficult data points so we see how this
becomes already a field of compromise
the authors bring up the idea that maybe
we can manage to formulate each data
acquisition effort as a game where
people by playing annotate data for free
isn't this a cool startup idea for
anyone ethically okay with this and the
final and hardest criterion is about
disincentivizing biased models so we
know that benchmarks are usually not
bias free they are following natural
distributions which are biased
reflecting the world as is biased
cloud-based source text is also biased
reflecting the annotator's bias this is
of course not news but the problem of
having these biases in the benchmark is
that models have the incentive to be
biased too they aim to beat the
benchmark so they must have these biases
too otherwise it would get examples
wrong when applying political
correctness to them this is of course a
huge pandora box of trouble and asks for
further research because there is no
one-size-fits-all solution for
mitigating bias this is not a compelling
reason to accept the status quo write
the author's point taken an idea of
going on about this is to create recite
additional expert constructed test data
sets and metrics that each isolate and
measure a specific type of bias next to
a primary task that the model is
evaluated on for me personally it was
surprising to read that we cite even for
the super glue benchmark which requires
users to compute tested metrics on the
dnc vinyl gender test set in order to
reveal test set results for any other
target task a large majority of papers
that report test set numbers omit this
metric and decline to report potentially
unflattering bias numbers
wow this depends so much on the mindset
of the community what you cynical miss
coffee bean you're not surprised eh ah
it's time to conclude this what have we
learned from this paper that data the
heart and brains of our models is
important but very hard to get it right
happily maturity in the field of machine
learning is developing where we move
just from model quality to data quality
it's best reflected in hugging phase
where next to their model hub they also
work on their data sets hub and no they
are not at all involved in us saying
this we are generally excited the sad
but also thrilling lesson from this
paper is that clearly more research is
needed on this data set domain if you
think that you are more into data
creation and model fiddling is not for
you go ahead and make cool progress for
data sets it is a cool place just
waiting for more smart people to work in
miss coffee bean hopes that the
benchmark creation field will become as
sexy as the new model architectures like
gans transformer versions etc in machine
learning hope we're getting there soon
thanks for watching until the end miss
coffee bean will let herself out
[Music]
you